i had one white friend his name was
timmy he was had red hair
he had a hook hello everyone
hola mis amigos you're listening to oh
my god hi
with me george
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere
what's his name george lopez george
lopez oh my god
omg omg hi oh my god
with hand sanitizer like when we ran
around we got dirty and you ended with
that [ __ ] dirt
ring on your door of course yeah and and
when and when you were rolling around in
the grass you [ __ ] itch like a
[ __ ] get all my
[ __ ] itching and [ __ ] but nobody had
hand sanitizer nobody had
really washed their hands and you when
you when you said to somebody
hey uh we're gonna eat so go wash your
hands yeah
i never did i was only a child yeah but
a lot of people did and a lot of people
didn't
but those were the things that built up
your immune system so the minute that
you started to
to put hand sanitizer or facial wipes
you were immediately breaking down your
own
natural body's immune system yeah i you
know
i heard some [ __ ] about that uh with
like nut allergies
the same thing they they because they
got so
precious about it all right and then
there was an article saying that
that's kind of what perpetuated this
this nut allergy yeah that's too clean i
said i would never remember to do it but
if i marry a dude
right here yeah because what happens is
so because when we were growing up there
wasn't
and as many people as there is now
but there was a hurry to make more
peanuts
so they started to make uh a synthetic
peanut
yeah and then this with that created
issues with allergies
just like when you started to have beef
or chicken or whatever and then now they
make chickens with no heads these
[ __ ]
are 18 pounds with no headaches and they
grow
you know nine times as fast as chickens
would
then everybody started to have the
hormones in the food the hormones in the
milk
the hormones everywhere in the chicken
and the peanuts and i believe that
that's where the allergies came from
yeah same with wheat
you know like the wheat they have today
is not
is just like not regular wheat like it
was back in the day
when people didn't have allergies to
weed and gluten all that stuff
now it's got all this other [ __ ] in
there to make it let me tell you
something when i was in elementary
school there was there was a girl her
name was brenda gluten
that was the last name gluten and she
had the biggest titties that you would
see
and so when someone said oh i'm gluten
free
all i could think about was brenda
gluten because she was like
in seventh grade and like
four and out she didn't wear a brush
seventh grader
i was in seventh grade 1973.
they didn't bend brows till 75. so
i mean she wore no brown like a gym
classic gluten
man bro and then you hear gluten later
on
and you you don't think it's in wheat
that wasn't a problem you think of it as
a good thing
you can't help it now where did you go
to school san fernando high oh you did
okay yeah you're but we're okay i guess
we should probably we should introduce
our wonderful guest
all right well uh since you're in charge
of introductions which are all [ __ ]
horrible
yeah this guy right here they're known
for horrible introductions but i'm good
i'd like to hear that
to me this dude is like
he's living the dream i consider him on
the on right on the ltd that's what i
say
uh living the dream man how about that
living what about uh
back in level ltd jeffrey i was born oh
that's a different ldd
well obviously he's a guitarist for
super group velvet revolver [ __ ]
how do you say obviously what if i don't
know
dave kushner i mean okay okay what about
the people today
like obviously so i already already got
out of the block don't you go work
with [ __ ] nasa oh obviously the tile
wasn't secure enough
and that's why you know they had an
issue they're not accepting applications
right now
we're gonna do introduction because this
is probably like the ninth i mean
this is our tenth introduction this is
my tenth introduction all of them have
been [ __ ] awful and finally we get
somebody that watches but
i'm very excited about this and here we
go if you're very excited
i can go in the hallway you guys work
this out no no this is fine
yeah we're learning as as we're doing
we're being bored [ __ ]
i'm in syndication oh yeah i've had a
stellar career
so you know that's right it's on youtube
people too who are listening right now
to not say
obviously we know who this is give him
the question
like we're in a little room okay today's
guest we're very fortunate
to have the guitarist of the super group
velvet revolver co-owner of monkey mind
music group currently working on motion
pictures television shows documentaries
and video games
ass cap winner and emmy awards so
[ __ ] fast though like like let
let it all sink in okay all right let's
enjoy it okay let's do it again
all right okay today's guest don't do it
slower just do it right
he's guitars for super group
right thank you number one that's great
co-owner of monkey mind music group
yes right check as cap winner emmy award
nominated
for theme song of sons of anarchy
correct
this life yes that's the name ladies and
gentlemen
dave kushner thank you dave first of all
i i would want to just say thank you for
for inviting yourself to the show like
we
they found us which is most amazing
yeah thank you yeah i'm driving all over
burbank
where were you born where'd you go to
school i was born in
l.a born in the uh
hospital hospital kaiser on sunset in
vermont
my whole history took place on vermont
okay so i'm saying we're not that yeah
that's why i live over there some
sunshine from yeah yeah
i don't know if it's like east lot it's
not east la but it's like east hollywood
almost yeah it's like
in between now silver lake and hollywood
so i guess scientology are you a suntan
just because if you are not
let's hold hands where the spaceship
takes us away let's go
that used to be cedars where the
scientology building is across from
kaiser that's that used to be cedars so
my parents met at lacc on vermont
i was born on at kaiser on sunset
vermont what's lacc
los angeles city college well you know i
went to
i went to west valley occupational
center which is at least 45 miles away
that's why
there is a tractor your parents met
there are your parents still together
my mom's passed away my dad is
lives in santa monica all right right oh
man but um we
yeah we grew up i went to bancroft
junior high uh
and went to fairfax have you ever heard
of bankruptcy
i don't know bankrupt generally fairfax
yes bankrupt's like uh
you know what trejo's donuts is i do
it's right there
right around the corner oh nice what was
that before trejo's donuts
not only yeah it was something yeah not
only was it donut time
but right up the right up that same
street that there was a
del taco across the street but right
above the street
is where john goodman
met the dude
with his his undies and the
the uzi when they went to go give the
money to the guys
in the big lebowski right he pulled up
in the parking lot of that place which
is right by there
and he goes you don't think i was
rolling in this place naked did you and
right there in that area that's where
bancroft is it's right around the corner
dirty is white del taco dude i remember
taco
at walgreens i went into that del taco
because
there was a guy they had these shirts
there was like their their sayings
and it said shut up and eat your beans
on the back of that shirt that's awesome
and i went into that del taco and i said
i said can i buy one of those shirts and
they're like oh no it's just employees
and then one of the employees was like
oh dude i'll sell you my shirt come back
out at three and that's how my shift is
over
and he was he sold me his huge
shut up shirt for 20 bucks
it was awesome listen man there's no way
that if if a [ __ ] employee is wearing
a shirt that says shut up at each of
these should it turn into a [ __ ]
walgreens
yeah they should have turned into the
first second story del taco that's right
so great
that's man all right so um
where does the music come from that was
your father in the music grandfather
like how far back
can you trace music in your life so so
my mom's side
of the family is all mexican the valdez
and taurus married and then
you know made uh so that's why don't say
it like that like
how was that growing up well it's it's
funny that's why i'm here
is to get to be more mexican and i heard
you could help me with that i couldn't
because i'm not mexican enough dude like
first of all you've been driving for 31
years
that's very mexican but i
when we fill out the application okay
i'll i'll co-sign to that yeah
but when you're growing up what was well
said you feel less mexican
well it's funny so okay so uh my mom
moved to l.a from iowa right and there's
a ton of mexicans in the middle of the
country
because i guess they all moved into in
the 20s moved into the middle of the
country to build the railroads
so there was like the chinese on the
coasts and all the mexicans moved
came up from uh mexico so there was this
big
so i have a a huge uh big extended
mexican family
in iowa wow man that's that's awesome so
so they came together the valdez and the
tauruses and they went into
uh settled into iowa they
you know made my mom my mom
because she didn't her and her
and her sister and stuff they spoke
english more than spanish so that they
could talk and not
and their parents wouldn't know what
they were saying you know to like kind
of get over on the parents
teenagers it's totally the opposite of
what yeah usually it is because our
parents wouldn't
speak in spanish so you wouldn't know in
english yeah so then
so by the time my mom moved out here and
everything
you know she didn't really speak a lot
of spanish
when i was growing up so i never learned
spanish really i mean i can you know
glean
words here and there but not not the way
i want to
and uh so yeah and then my dad's
full-on just jewish russian jew
white guy and uh so then where did they
meet
at lacc at los angeles city college yeah
okay
and uh and they were young you know like
23 20
when they got together then i was born
and then uh
my dad
my dad bought my mom uh an acoustic
uh nylon string so it was just sitting
in my house
and then when i was arriving at a guitar
because it was your mom musical
did she mike was her family music my d
my grandfather my great-grandfather
this is no lie used to play guitar
at the intermission at the bull fights
in michoacan
uh wow you know years ago okay let me
say something
this is the thing that i mean dave man
respect because
these are the things that nobody knows
that at bull fights and at
in in los angeles at all those great
theaters a lot of them are gone orpheum
the los angeles theater all those great
theaters intermission of movies and
intermission of bullfights and
intermission of
any activity somebody would come out and
play guitar at the
orpheum theater when in between movies a
guy would come out
on a horse dressed as a mariachi and do
rope tricks
in between movies so you know
when you go see listen i hate to
racially divide but
you know i do all the time if you went
to go see [ __ ] jaws
and another movie came on nothing
the popcorn that [ __ ] danced and the
soda that talked
let's go out to the lobby that [ __ ]
but when you went to a [ __ ] theater
that had latino or bullfights
uh you actually saw a live performance
and
that that's incredible right there man
yeah thank you for that
yeah so that's uh yeah that that's uh
that was my great grandfather my my
grandfather my mom's dad
uh uh he played guitar
and was an artist so it's like it's cool
because i have a
i have his old acoustic guitar amazing
but the case that it comes in is all
painted like you did painting on the
outside of the case so it's really cool
so i had that he did it yeah he did it
uh
i it's just like you know flowers and
whatever but
but i do have this really incredible
last supper so when he was he was in the
war and when he was sick
like years later he was in the hospital
and what war because there's a lot of
wars
you know blood crips there's a lot of
that you come you know
it was in world war ii
but he um i think it was world war ii i
could be wrong
you know sorry if i am but he um
they they used to do these you know
those like
it's like copper colored it's like a
thin sheet of copper
and you do like a relief painting on it
right sure
so he did one of the last supper that i
have it's really cool
when he was in the hot but it's like so
detailed dude like the
the toenails like these little toenails
on the feet under the table
and everything it's only this big you
know but luckily i have that too and
so uh but i didn't really know him that
well
growing up and i know he was uh
you know i only i probably met him or
saw him a handful of times but you saw
him when you saw him around
and things like that but he lived in
iowa and i lived in l.a so
you know i saw him a couple times and
then um
yeah then my mom wasn't super musical
but she grew up uh i mean you know but
she got really involved in
a lot of art so i i had no so it was in
the family art
yeah i had no intention of playing um
music until i was about
14 15. yeah and all i want to do is be a
graphic artist
like that was my thing my mom was really
involved in this thing called uh barrio
mobile art studio which was like a it
was almost like an ice cream truck like
a big ice cream truck
and it was in east l.a and it was like
this like group
kind of contingency of mexican artists
and
she would it was an esla and they would
drive this
truck with art supplies wow into like
these different parks and stuff in east
l.a
and park and then you know kids would
come and they and there was like
these established artists like this was
this dude gronk
you know no of course gronk yeah so
gronk baby stabbed me once like when i
was a kid and like she
knew gronk and like a bunch of other
dudes self-help graphics was another
thing that he did
she was involved in so she but wait a
minute let's talk about gronk man
because gronk is a famous chicano artist
yeah
and and what do you mean he babysat you
because he was just
like you know a couple times when like i
was you know i guess
my mom was like hey can you watch my kid
i'm gonna go like he was like okay cool
you know before he was you know big and
when he was still
coming up and they had uh this they had
the mobile art studio but they had this
uh graphics contingency called self-help
graphics in esla and my mom worked with
with a lot of non-profit um you know
uh chicano art so gronk became a famous
chicano artist and
and in your recollection of him what
stood out
to because you know you as an artist
a music and an artist what stood out
about being around gronk that you that
you remember that
was a little bit different because an
artist is really different than
everybody else
yeah and what stood out about gronk that
you remember i got to be honest dude
i would i want to make up some [ __ ] and
be really cool but like
you know he was just a little you know
eccentric and and just
different and cool and but i i was
really young so i don't remember a lot
of
you know how he was or being around him
you know it was a couple times but
but it was just cool you know like it
really turned me on to
all of that like posada and you know
like art like that because that's
i was into you know that kind of
graphic art style right you know and and
learned about
all of that stuff and and wood block
printing and you know all that different
those different styles of
part that they would do so it was just
cool man i was exposed to a lot of that
stuff when at a really young age
um but you know since then and and like
uh
like the dia de los muertos parades and
[ __ ] because the
they would always be a part of that
right now because it was in east l.a and
then we would go
down to olvera street and yep you know
check it out so
and the thing is is like it's kind of
faded away a little
you know like my mom died about 10 years
ago and you know
and it's funny because it's like it's
still
you know it's still there but it's not
here you know what i'm saying it's not
as it's not right in front of me it's a
little more
like over there and and i miss it
time to time you know i think about it
and i think about like you know every
halloween i'm like
oh wait which day is day of the dead i
got to take my kids because i have two
kids and i'm like
i want to take him down to the you know
every year it's like i'm going to take
him down to the parade down in east l.a
and then i forget or i miss the day or
you know because it's
it's just like oh sure you're right so
it's it's
it's something i you know i'm always
kind of trying to get back to
you know what i mean but you know day of
the dead is a is a big thing in mexico
right so so but here in the united
states
i would say that you know i grew up in
san fernando you know
i'm going to be 60 the 23rd and even
growing up
in the valley there in san fernando
mission hills pacoima
that it wasn't as big a thing with with
us even back then
so yeah um yeah i understand i
understand that
but then it was like what uh was it the
book of life
yeah is that the movie it it shed light
on it it's a bigger thing now since that
movie
right yeah oh there was wait was it book
of life or there was
there was another movie coco yeah yeah
yeah
but i mean those you know like when i
see those kind of movies i get all
emotional
yeah you know because it's like i have a
lot of history but but
but i i do believe that independently
even before the book of life or coco
that
that independently the day of the dead
was celebrated individually within
families and back then nobody
nobody really thought of it as being a
holiday
but day of the dead that as families you
would gather things that someone
who had passed liked and put them out
together
and you know and and kind of
give them the respect of of being gone
but it was more as a family thing and
not
as a universal or looked at as a kind of
a holiday yeah
you know more like a day of remembrance
i dare remember scared
um and i don't even think if you look at
like um
you know uh whether it's valentine's day
or whether it's saint pat i mean it's
not really a holiday
but it's a made-up holiday but
the day of the dead was something that
was traditionally brought from
you know latinos in mexico and out here
and it was more of a remembrance that
became something
later on yeah um so so yeah
yeah that that's true so when you so
when um
uh at 14
13 14 and you saw the guitar like what
music
what kind of music were you into at that
time
i mean was the music that drew you to
the guitar or was it a friend or was it
something you saw because at that time i
think you know there was a lot more
music shows you know
like american advanced amazon or you can
see like 14 special
you were close to mtv starting out right
14 that's like 81
like yeah i was it was right before that
i don't even think we had cable though
oh there you go you know what i mean
like you did
like you had like two through 13 and you
didn't have
cable yet you know and that was like a
whole other
kind of thing do you remember before
cable oh yeah oh yeah
my my uncle my uncle uh freddie lived in
north
northridge receda and they had cable and
i would go over there sometimes and you
yeah the first time i saw him tv i was
at my
uncle freddie's house in in um in
in northridge over there by uh i'd like
to say uh
balboa and uh um
uh devon devonshire uh roscoe and balboa
over in that area but i lived in
machines that wasn't there yet
so so uh the whole mtv thing yeah they
they got that yeah yeah i i uh
i don't even remember i remember the i
remember like
public access and cable and pbs you know
like
it would but um but what were you and
your friends into like in elementary
school
or or in junior high i got into
you know sabbath and oh nice and uh
did you guys skateboard did you bmx were
you doing yeah so i went so i grew up
you know leading to the band like slash
and i
went to bancroft and junior high
together he was great ahead of me
but like he was super into bmx and i was
into
skateboarding because so like uh
i started around 12 13 going to marina
del rey skate park when it was still
there
you know out in marina del rey there was
a bus that went from
fairfax and and wilshire the 877 take
you
all the way and leave you right in front
of the skate park it will go on the
freeway and everything
so i used to go to skate park a lot and
got into
before i got into punk rock i was you
know into
uh sabbath the who you know all those
hendricks uh zeppelin
all of those bands were a huge influence
for me like really
i was really like i would watch the kids
all right or i'd watch you know the song
remains the same and
that was like my whole world really at
that time and what was the first show
you went to and where was it like who'd
you go
the first concert big concert i ever
went to that i remember was the summer
strut
it was at anaheim stadium it was
scorpions
lover boy iron maiden and foreigner
and foreigner was the headliner did you
go to that i went to day in the green
same lineup oh really in the agreement
oakland was that same level oh wow
yeah yeah crazy what year was that um
for me it was remember
it was it had to be 81. yeah it's
something like that maybe 79 80
79 between 79 and 81. yeah so i would
have been
some 54 so yeah we're the same
i would have been around yeah yeah yeah
that was the first show i can remember
and what do you think man were you it
was awesome dude i mean i was that
like eddie out yeah
for me it was uh because i was into like
foreigner you know i was into all those
not lover boy really but uh
maiden and and i remember that they on
when they did jukebox jukebox hero yeah
and they brought out like the 40
the inflatable yeah already put jukebox
and then it blows up like at the big
yeah that was climax of the song so it
was great and there was a big
fight like it's funny like the
at anaheim stadium the the upper tears
started fighting with everyone on the
field and they just started throwing
like
uh uh cups full of rocks and dirt
and so it's like at one point you're
just like oh [ __ ] you couldn't hide
anywhere because you're just like
on the grass you know it's like you
can't really you could try and make it
to the side but you're just in the
middle you know and and
people are from the upper tears are
throwing [ __ ] and people from down below
are throwing [ __ ] back up and
well you know you know i'm gonna i'm the
oldest here but but
when people listen to this and now when
they have those things
very rarely do because you know now
there's djs and there's rap and
and there's uh not not as many outdoor
festivals
but i went to the world music festival
in 1979
it was a friday maybe it was a saturday
and sunday
my friend alberto worked at church's
chicken in san fernando and and we went
when he got off at midnight and he
brought a bunch of chicken we drove down
to the coliseum
and the next day it was toto the
scorpions
blackfoot molly hatchet ufo
uh van halen co-headline with aerosmith
ted nugent
and then the next day toto played and uh
you know man it
changed your life none of our parents
were there we [ __ ] slept outside and
[ __ ] sleeping bags
outside by the sports arena nobody gave
a [ __ ] we were gone
we were still in high school man i was
17 years old yeah
the world music festival yeah uh uh um
when blac you know we were all we're all
[ __ ] loaded it
so black black sabbath comes down and
it's
and they're doing the rain thing you
know the sh and the and the and the tone
thing yeah thing what song is that
black black sabbath so that so i'm
standing on the on the on the
on the field of the coliseum right by
the track there's a little bit of like a
three-inch
curb that separates the track from the
thing
right you know what i'm talking about
and i'm standing there with my friends
and and uh uh uh i think ronnie james
deal was singing with black sabbath at
that time they had heaven and hell
and and uh i'm standing there and the
the sun's going down you hear the chimes
what is
this that stands before
i [ __ ] went down they [ __ ] look up
and my friends are like are you all
right i was so [ __ ] but the minute i
heard the first
black sabbath it live it [ __ ]
weakened my legs and i went completely
down and they played heaven and hell and
they played uh
wishing well and all that stuff man yeah
dude oh my god it's incredible dude and
i remember that my friend ernie that
made the show
after you know ernie would always get
married always make fun of his mom and
there was a lady that was
a girl that was naked completely naked
and and tits hanging out big bush she
was 79.
and then and ernie hadn't seen her yet
and uh we were always making fun of his
mom so i go
erin i don't know your mom had a ticket
and he looked and he got mad and he
[ __ ] took off so every time we got
mad he
[ __ ] left we didn't steal the rest of
the weekend i don't know how he got home
but
that was like me at the us festival dude
the same thing like we went
i i was like 6 17 it was in 83
i think and we we went to the heavy
metal day with van halen and scorpions
and
motley and ozzy and all right and we i
remember it was like me
and two guys from slash's band at the
time
not slash but the in high school he had
a band called titus sloan and it was
me and ronnie and adam who was a drummer
and and bass player in his band
and my friend louie and we drove in a i
don't even know who savannah was
and we drove out glenn helen yeah we had
a keg of beer
and we drove all the way out there and
we took mushrooms and
the night before same thing in the
parking lot and i was like
and there was like what was that i do
because there was always like the right
yeah it was like a i just remember
seeing this
10 foot tall shadowy thing that looked
like eddie from iron maiden
and i was like so [ __ ] up i was like
do you see that
are you seeing like we all like a couple
people said they saw it but no one ever
figured out what it was
and it was you know and then the next
day we we passed out
we went you had to walk like almost like
45 minutes to get to the
to the area and you know it was
it was amazing but it was miserable at
the same time because you're just
in the middle of a crowd so many people
you've got a great spot
so you're like you don't want to go go
to the bathroom or get water you don't
think to bring
water or anything like that you're 17.
you're dehydrated you've been drinking
all night you need
mushrooms [ __ ] everybody takes water
now back then nobody
even thought about bringing [ __ ]
water man i didn't have a way to bring
it you just always think of a fountain
anyway so you didn't i remember my
friend
the drummer adam he left he's like dude
i gotta get
i don't feel so good i gotta get some
water because we were walking i remember
we were walking on these train tracks
like
like you said a little three-inch thing
and he had he had fallen off the train
track and cut his ankle
but i guess he like lost a lot of blood
that we didn't really
realize so the next day you know you're
in the middle it's
[ __ ] hot everyone's dehydrated and
he's like i don't feel so good i'm gonna
go to the
i don't know i could get some water i
remember waters were like
three bucks which we were like three
dollars for all water
and he ended up in the tent like in the
medics tent
all day we never heard from him again
like same thing like you're like ernie
dude yeah we never knew what happened to
him
we were like oh should we leave like i
don't know if we should leave like
we should yeah same thing and then we
[ __ ] found out that he was in the
medics tent all day and
he somehow he got home or something
happened you know what they would do
they were
laid out he didn't see any of the
concert i don't he was in there all day
oh he heard it missed the other they
used to [ __ ] shoot they used to shoot
water out at the crowd
nobody had water they would they would
shoot water out at you
yeah back no bottle of water back then
it was all like canteens and [ __ ] if you
had to
yeah really there was no way to really
but no one thought about it so so
you went to school with saul hudson
slash
yeah yeah yeah slash and i became buds
later on but but you went to school with
slash right yeah
yeah and you play guitar he slash was
into like bmx and skateboarding and
stuff right
and then you guys were you in a slight
first band
no no we were friends but we
were uh we didn't really ever i i
didn't start playing guitar till like
ninth or tenth grade you know and then i
was just
it my whole thing was like i saw the
nylon guitar i tried to play stairway to
heaven
it was too hard they had music classes
at the school they're like you have to
play with
you can't play with a pick you know
because it was like regular
guitar and the classes were more you
know regimen
and so and i couldn't play sarah heaven
so i just gave up you know and i was
like ah
[ __ ] it and then a year later
uh punk rock came along you know and all
those bands like black flag
and circle jerks and all those bands
were playing the starwood was still
there
uh did you go to the star wars yeah the
whiskey the starwood
all those it was amazing you know like
the decline of western civilization like
when that movie
came out i went to the premiere on
hollywood
have you seen the decline westminster no
i know of the movie if anybody
uh that's listening or watching or
anything if you're into
music or whatever but if you're just
into just rock and the way things
started and the people that were
involved
people that you probably will never hurt
hear of
but that were awesome in that time
that's what to watch and i think there's
maybe four episodes of it
no there well there's two movies there's
the metal years yeah oh yeah yeah which
is like
which is good too it's funny and
whatever but this one is
just a straight-up movie about the dude
that's in the pool with his mom and he's
that's the metal one that's the
uh who's that chris he's chris holmes is
that guy still alive
i don't know this [ __ ] is
pouring him remember he's in the pool
yeah
floating his mom's his mom's hanging by
the side of the pool and he's like oh
yeah i rock and
he did and he's just pouring like a
bottle of smirnoff
oh my god he was a guitar player in wasp
he's alive are you serious
yeah chris holmes a blonde yeah yeah i
know that was
yeah but so that's that's what happened
then some girl i knew
was in a band called math society which
was like these little kid punk bands
those were all the kids
that i was friends with in school and we
all went to school together
and then she taught me how to play a bar
chord and i was like wait what
and and then i was like wait i can just
move this up and down and i can play
like any song
like and and i just no i dude my
i have this puppy and the puppy bit my
oh playing my finger like right on where
the
where i do to play the guitar does it
just be i mean i got like
bites everywhere i got this little puppy
like that that doesn't matter what kind
of dog is that
so so the barcode the barcode
yeah and then i just got really into it
and and
got into you know i was in the punk rock
already and i was like oh this is how
you play this song
and wait i can play that song too and i
you know because all the punk rock songs
are mostly bar chords
and you were 14-ish at that point i was
16. okay so 15 16. and then uh
then that was it i was off and running
and then
uh those guys the mad society guys my
buddy mark
vashon uh and this guy louis metz
they both were you know super just into
music like we even though we were in a
punk rock we would listen to
the who and and sabbath and all these
band ufo
all those bands and then uh and then we
got into
uh and then mark was a guitar player and
so mark was like
i remember mark would because they had
like split level apartments
like they and you could go in between
apartments
and where were the apartments at on
gardiner and santa monica
where we are in other places yeah where
okie dogs used to be
then now it's a fat burger and and uh
i remember the like mark would always
come home like come home
because you know uh we would still buy
records then
and there's like had like aaron's
records over by fairfax
these different record stores and he i
remember him coming home and saying like
dude when the first aussie record came
out he's like dude i heard this guy's
better than eddie van halen
you know what he it was like the with
randy rhodes yeah right now you know
yeah yeah we sat around and we listened
and we're like oh that's some amazing
pretty [ __ ]
yeah lizard was pretty [ __ ] amazing
amazing yeah he was crazy trained and uh
yeah randy was smoking on yeah amazing
yeah
and then you know just different guitar
players and then it was cool because he
was really into
like when ing malmsteen was in that band
steeler which was like a local la band
at first and he's like oh and then they
bring home this record be like
this guy's better than that guy you know
it's always yeah this guy's better than
randy rhodes and this guy's better than
ingbayer this guy's better than that
so it was cool man we just sat around
and like smoked weed and
did other things and just [ __ ] listen
to music
and you know try to play guitar
beautiful and what was the turning point
though so are you more comfortable like
with rhythm or were you
early on or was was lead like you just
want to be the guy i
i was into both you know i i think i got
to a point where
i get when i got into it i got really
kind of obsessed over playing and i
would just sit in a room and play all
day and
you know try and place leads and
whatever and i remember this time like
i took acid and i was like i remember
like you know those old school
uh the tape recorders and i remember
like oh dude i get it now this is like i
get hendrix i get it all
and i i have this like strat and i was
playing all this stuff and i was like oh
my god
i'm you know i'm so awesome and then i
like
and i taped it and i listened back and i
was like this is [ __ ]
awful it's like
but i i could move my fingers around and
and i was a really bad student in high
school and
you know uh all of us dudes slash
everyone i know
took the ended up taking the ged instead
of graduating you know
to get out early i got out at 11th grade
and
you know i told my mom i want to go to
music school so i ended up going to mi
because i knew i could move my fingers
but i didn't know where to put them
you know and she's like you can just go
to and
what's it like to get an mi because you
know i see i i would i would drive
around and see those guys out there but
what's the process of getting in there i
don't
i mean back then it was just
just bass guitar and drums you know it
was like
bass instituted technology guitar and it
was like a building on hollywood
boulevard
and now it's huge now it's like music
concerting across the street
they've got like you know the engineer
school and this school and that school
but back then it was really small and it
was one floor
in a in a building on holly boulevard
and you just
went i think i went in and i just played
for them so you
kind of audition you do actually yeah
you gotta you gotta know how to play
yeah
it's that's all you do you don't take
any academics it's just
playing guitar they teach you how to
read music they teach you
ear training sight reading uh
uh harmony and theory like they teach
you
everything about that's what's great
about it it's like and there's no other
academics to get in the way it's just
like i want to learn
you know and now they do accreditation
if you want to be a teacher whatever
back then it was just like
it's like just a trade school for your
instruments
but do you want music to shred that's
awesome do you remember music i don't i
mean i did
no slash doesn't read music right no we
both you you forget
it's like a it's a user lose kind of
thing yeah it's a thing you have to use
in order to well i don't think it's a
user lose i i just think
a lot of a lot of dudes don't really
learn how to
how to because if you can play fast if
you start to shred
um you just remember just remember the
stuff like
mr van halen and i were very close
friends
and in that time that i knew him and he
would play them for me i would say did
you learn how to
read music and he would say no and i
said well how do you know that and then
of course you record everything and they
would say i would just re
i would just remember it yeah i would
just remember it and i would have to
believe
on the creative side of it when you're
making the music you're composing
you're not writing it down because like
you said you'll remember it so i mean i
i would have to go all the way back from
the beatles and stuff they they some of
them had classes too but none of them
read music as well because they were
creating all the time and that's how
they remember their stuff
is that is that somewhat i mean dude now
honestly now when i when i write stuff
uh
even now i i literally take my phone
and i video what i'm doing with my left
hand because
i always try like i'm
a lot more like when i was in bell
revolver right
like uh uh duff and slash and matt you
know had been in guns and roses for so
long together
and they had this thing that they would
do at rehearsal where they would kind of
crowd around
duff and slash would kind of crowd
around matt you know just stand right in
front of his drum set
and those guys are really good at
you know slash would come up with some
[ __ ] crazy
mind-bending you know riff and then
duff would walk over and look at it and
be like oh yeah okay
and like get it in a second and i'm the
guy that's like
wait oh can you can you show me that
again you know and i'd sit there and
really like study it
and it would take me like a what really
i would want to say like
let me just take this home and like
really get my head around yeah like i'm
that guy
so you know i will even now like oh
if i'm going to write something i'll try
like 20 different things but because i
don't
remember like oh that's an a flat minor
that's a b
suspended chord with a flat nine or
whatever that stuff is
i forget and i'm just doing shapes
basically so i need to record it and see
because
i will record something and have no idea
how to play it
unless i i could see myself well let's
not skip to a
velvet revolver uh yeah um
should we start it should we whatever
you want how did you get to
vault though i mean where did you feel
like you were a good enough guitar
player you were in a lot of bands right
yeah you were ready yeah yeah i played
in danzig i played in
this band infectious grooves i yeah
played in a punk band called wasted
youth i played in
tons of bands and and i was the asian
the the the the those
zilch yeah yeah that was a that's a
whole crazy story but
i mean but yeah if you tell us a little
bit about that i mean how'd that come
about i mean that's
so before that was right before velvet
revolves yeah right yeah
well so really fast it's like the
the trajectory was so i was
uh i got in wasted youth when i
was like 88 i think so it was like the
later version of wasted youth when they
kind of like
was punk rock but it was kind of metal
too so i was just out of school
uh we we had mutual friends um
and i got in the band i didn't know any
of those guys when i went in
and but joey castillo the drummer
who later on went to play with uh in
danzig and then queens of the stone age
he was in for a long time now he's in a
band called the bronx and
he so he and i became really good
friends in that band
and then uh there was a couple bands
later where he ended up playing in
danzig
then you know he down the line asked me
to try out for danzig then i was in
danzig for a while
and then uh in between i
the i played in this band electric love
hogs we made a record
the producer uh was doing infectious
grooves record
next door and so i went and played on
that record and you know it was all kind
of
very um incestuous you know yeah because
they're growing up here everyone knows
everybody
sure yeah and so um so it just kept
going like that you know and then i'd be
and along the way i you know just
had regular jobs in between you know
where i was i would work and build sets
and
do that kind of stuff and and so like
dan's like what happened i was in that
for nine months but i said something
that glenn didn't like and then i got
kicked out
you know and then me and and uh the bass
player but
like that like you said something yeah
dude what did you say to him
that's good listen listen i i had a dj
working with me
and we were uh in austin texas
at uh wherever the longhorns play
and i had sold that place out uh ut
and the dj who was brand new said [ __ ]
uh who who has to go in front of all
these people
like while we were doing really kind of
like on stage check yeah
it was me yeah so for him to say like oh
my god this place is going to be
full who the [ __ ] is going up there and
it was me i fired that [ __ ]
yeah after that after that show because
yeah
it's like you don't want somebody with
you that's going to be like oh my god
who's going to
yeah how can anybody perform that's
exactly what happened to me because
really
yeah i remember we all went out to the
viper room
and it was he it was the band me joey
glenn
and blasco who plays with ozzy and we
we uh we went out and he had just made
this record danzig 5
and it just didn't sound like a ban on
me because it wasn't you know it's like
he had
jared cantrell and all these other
guests on it
some guests and there was a lot of drum
programming and it didn't sound like the
first four records where it was like
guitar bass drums yep
and i and we were just in a conversation
and i remember saying like yeah that
doesn't really sound like a
that record just doesn't really sound
like a band it just sounds more like a
you know not just doesn't sound like the
you know the old man
and he took so much offense to that that
i got fired the next day wow and how
were you
notified of that joey because joey and i
were friends he brought me in so he was
the one that had that
but but i think him getting that pissed
off i think i mean you know somebody
doesn't get that mad unless
you're you're on point right i think
well he might have said something to him
because you know it was his record it
was like
it was really more about him even more
so because before it was like
you know the same band for four records
and then uh
those guys all left and then it was joey
and there was no like
set band so i think he might have felt
you know kind of like i i'm this is more
you know vulnerable
not vulnerable but you know like in a
sense like i'm really laying it out here
um this is my record this is you know i
played some guitar on it i did this i
did that
right you know so whatever but then i
got kicked out and then
uh you know went back to work and then
got
and then it just kept going like that
like then joey he was always with joey
joey
did this project with uh this thing
called zilch which was
so there's this band called x japan
which is a huge
like the biggest rock band in japan back
in the
90s and have you heard about japan no
i've not never have not
so this guy i hadn't either so this then
the guitar player was this guy hide
and he was like as big as michael
jackson
in which i heard and none of this i
believe i was kind of like what really
right really and so um
he came and he did this project with uh
with joey and these other guys and and
he
this guy he wanted to make like an
american like a rob zombie
type of record so he made this record he
went back to japan
they were getting ready to do this tour
and he he
killed himself he died self asphyxiation
he like
you know on a doorknob like so
and then uh i guess later they
wanted to still like honor his memory
and do this record
and his brother said okay i approve
and then joey calls me and is like hey
do you want to play guitar in this thing
and i was like
okay and so i go down he's like all
right we're going to japan in 10 days
and he's telling me this whole story and
i'm like wait what
he goes so there's this record executive
guy and if they look at you kind of
funny
you know they but they're but they're
kind of judging you because you're kind
of feeling these big shoes and
blah blah and i'm like okay but i really
didn't understand
the the the bigness of it and it was so
funny dude
i told my uncle this whole story and
he's like
oh hitti i saw that guy's funeral on cnn
like there was like 70 000 people at
this guy's funeral in japan
i was like and that was the show my
uncle didn't even know anything about
music dude he's just like
he was a librarian and a loyola merriman
he's just like like what
dude he's like i was like really and
then i went to
i went to uh japan
and then and hidey's brother sweetheart
brings me i'm in a hotel room and he
brings me these uh
vhs tapes you know just as a
as a good gesture of goodwill he's like
here's you know he didn't really speak
uh
english so the interpreter was like you
know he wants you to have these these
are his brother's shows from tokyo dome
and so hit a as a solo artist would sell
out multiple nights at tokyo dome
and i wat i sat dude this was the day
before the first show
i'm sitting in my hotel room by myself
watching these vhs
tapes of this guy that iconic
oh my god yeah dude and i was like like
literally in the streets there's [ __ ]
merchandise everywhere there's like
vendors and [ __ ]
i was [ __ ] freaking that would be
here like
it would be like uh seriously like
prince michael jackson
it was kind of like prince yeah like a
prince type of
except there was a lot anyways and you
had no idea so i had no idea until that
until the night before i was playing my
first show
and so you know then but it went amazing
you know there was like people were into
it and
and it was great and that was
my first introduction to being in japan
and all that and then
you know we went back a couple times we
did some we did like a three week tour
all over japan
wait a minute but incredible so so when
you're in your room watching that
watching that stuff and it's really
downing on you with this person man yeah
okay so then the net so overnight you
wake up in the morning and then you know
you have to go do that thing
what was it like before you almost
walked on stage
knowing that when you started to play
that everybody was expecting so much
from you
you know i i didn't is that a legitimate
question yeah no i had to kind of block
it out
you know what i mean it's like i think
as a it's [ __ ]
that's you yeah like [ __ ] nobody does
that i mean does anybody come out here
and pretended to be prince and and yeah
well not pretend it but has anybody come
out in an honor of prince and come out
and play
replacement like prince basically is
what you're saying no yeah no
ridiculous no you can't no yeah and he
pulled it off apparently so
yeah it was cool man it was uh i didn't
i just had to block it out
honestly like i was freaking out yeah
[ __ ]
freaking out yeah like in the in the
hotel room and i don't think there's
anything anybody can [ __ ]
say to you great story though you're
like who's this guy there's no
there's nothing anybody can say to you
like hey you know
it's not that big of a deal or don't
worry about it yeah it is a big deal
it's huge but i knew like the one thing
was good is like i saw how he was as a
performer
like he would just [ __ ] run up and
down and like he was like i mean he had
this huge pink mohawk
and he was just [ __ ] amazing like he
would just run around like crazy and he
was here he was there bubba
and so and that's kind of how i was
on stage two you know i run all over the
place and jump off things
yeah so i just was like dude i need i'm
gonna [ __ ] wear a kilt
and i'm gonna wear some big crazy boots
and you know wear
[ __ ] all kinds of weird [ __ ] and i
had this big yellow guitar and i was
like
you know [ __ ] it i'm gonna just go nuts
yeah do my thing and they appreciate it
yeah
and people were into it and and that's
what i did so
but yeah i was freaking out but well i'm
going to tell you something i've known a
lot of musicians you know i've been
friends with a lot of guitar players
but but i don't think any comedians even
but i don't think i've ever
sat across from anybody who had more
pressure to perform
at one particular point than than than
you did doing that
yeah it was a lot it was a lot hugely
[ __ ] significant
yeah performance yeah but it was cool
man the the
i love that's what like really
made me love japan and just like you
know the people and the the
the culture and like just learning
little things like like the coolest
thing is
that they do that i learned just
culturally was like
when people are standing around like in
a little group like even just like
outside a bar or whatever talking
they always open up the circle that's
like the thing is if someone comes in
you always open up the circle and let
the other person in wow you know and
it's like i've always you know i really
kind of paid attention to that kind of
[ __ ] or they
they the fans would even if they
they were just super you know excited
like standing there like
you know off to the side and they want
to come talk to you they would always
just wait
and they didn't like just run up to you
and be like hey man yeah i know
you know they're just like they wait and
they're they're like polite and they're
respectful
and you you know you'd look over and be
like oh come on you know i'll sign the
whatever
you know and they come over and they're
excited but they're just so
you know respectful and i love that
thing and they they would always hand
you the card with
uh like a business card with with two
hands
it's as a sign of respect like you know
we're doing something
you know here's here's what i do you
know and i respect what you do and like
i'm giving you this then maybe we can do
something together you know
like there was a lot of stuff i learned
about the culture that i really
you know appreciated going forward that
which has no
resemblance to how we live in the united
states at all none at all
because we haul ass to you yeah we just
run you over
and be like so stefan marbury i don't
know if you've seen a document there's a
documentary
on either netflix or somewhere almost
stefan marbury who
who was very good and then you know he
was a troubled player
with the knicks and every every place he
went he was troubled
but also like the people of new york
expected so much for my mind he
could he couldn't um make anybody happy
that was a basketball fan in whatever
team he went to
he ended up not wanting to but he ended
up going to japan
and playing basketball and there
you know in watching this documentary
he he learned a lesson in his life that
almost like what you're talking about
that they loved him so much and they
respected him so much
that it changed his dynamic
and the way that he thought about people
was not the way that it was in the
united states where
you know show us what you can do they
were appreciative of his talent
and when some some kid or somebody said
like
i i can't imagine you know meeting you
and just showing him the respect i was
in tears because
you see what this is like where
everybody tries to bring you down here
but over there they respect you for who
you are and they love you for your
ability which is
i'm gonna say contrary it's not even
anywhere near
what's going on so so yeah that that
that that's uh that's awesome man there
you go
it was cool man it really kind of
changed my
thinking you know about a lot of stuff
but um
but yeah that was so so that was before
you went to velvet revolver of course
now now not to jump ahead too far but
but was that pressure
relatable to what the pressure you had
when you were in the band velvet
revolver
no to start with that was way worse way
worse
yeah i mean not easy but you know uh
right after
zilch i was playing with dave navarro
who he and i have been friends for a
long time he had
kind of done a solo thing and we started
we toured for his solo record
so dave navarro um do you know who doug
goodman is
no his tour manager is skinny dude wiry
dude wears shorts all the time
i know i know she is addictions to her
manager but
yeah i know who he is around him not so
much this [ __ ] has the worst
breath
he's the greatest guy but does he has a
worth worse break
that's that's this won't make it but
anyways
so but we i inherited him from almost uh
we had a guy die uh on tour a manager
that died on tour
and then another guy came in what was
that guy's name mark one
boy i can't remember his last name uh
mark somebody and then
we ended up with doug but he worked with
uh james
yeah got he i think he actually got in a
fight with perry ferrell and
and [ __ ] pinned him he choked him out
and got him fired the other day
[ __ ] fired his ass for choking him
out and then he worked with
oh i know doug yeah dude he wait he's a
guy that drop have you ever driven with
him
yeah he's like crazy but wait a minute
so we were coming from here that's what
i'm talking about right
yeah yeah yeah i would be in the
backseat said hey doug man you got to
[ __ ] get slowed out you're going a
hundred
dollars not into the [ __ ] whole road
rage yeah the [ __ ] almost ran
over marine in washington dc
yeah could you you know what is there
anything worse than running over a
[ __ ] military man i'll tell you a
funny story
the funny thing about about doug is i
swear to god i often think
the light bulb just went on with i went
dude i remember i used to drive with
doug
sometime in a van and i remember
thinking because i went onto
a tour with uh james too and i remember
doug
and we were driving a van i would get
like kind of nervous i remember once i
was sitting in the front seat in the
passenger seat and i was like
i'm gonna sit in the back you know like
just i don't lie through a windshield
and he but he was always like trying to
find like
always forward you know perpetual
emotion like
and i swear to god dude once in a while
i'll be driving and i'll kind of go into
that mode
the doug goodman driving mode and not in
a bad way but just think like okay i'm
going to go forward here and if i go
over there i'll go forward there
and it's so funny like it's almost like
i took a little bit of positive
listen but the small bugger
rarely based he's a great guy great tour
manager
very extensively yeah what if he wasn't
a [ __ ] great guy
and he wasn't again that wouldn't he
he's a good tour man yeah but is he a
great guy you don't [ __ ] you
don't know him you've never been to his
[ __ ] house
so so anyway so we're on the road with
him and and
what what he's good at is eliminating
excessive costs like he'll drive a car
instead of taking
a guy who's gonna drive you yeah we're
flying private spending [ __ ] millions
of dollars this guy's like we're gonna
fight commercial we're gonna do this
we're gonna we're gonna get a bus
we're gonna do that yeah i you won't buy
are you gonna [ __ ]
kiss his ass again or you know let me
tell the truth no no i'm just saying
well he didn't want us to pay for a
driver he would drive himself
that's true imagine there's not many
people do that so he did yeah and this
[ __ ] would eat [ __ ] that
nobody would eat we went to one of those
anti-maze places on the roadster
yeah yeah and he he bought hot dogs
wrapped in like dough yeah yeah and he
he and and and to be in the back seat
and watch him eat
where he would just open his mouth and
just put
almost all of this hot dog inside there
right there
like you're just like i would look at
him i would look at brian i would just
be like
and he would just go just like it was
the most delicious thing he's ever
touched in his life
right so he bought the you know willie
davis was my favorite player of diners
and they his name was three dog
so well as we're driving he just
[ __ ] powers three [ __ ]
doe wrapped hot dogs in his mouth yeah
so i go hey doug i'm gonna call you
three dogs
and he goes hang on a second that
[ __ ] put through he he slid
a couple more down there he's on the way
to call me now like well that rude
call you five dogs that doesn't matter
i had to talk to him right a a lot of
times
in the car saying hey man roll down a
window i'm not trying to
i'm not trying to to die on the right in
the middle of the night
he goes he like he puts his foot i know
and anybody who's not
like trying to give he's like mad at
yeah if they're not
trying to go 85 he's pissed that he's
like get out of the way [ __ ] i
know we drove
i think we drove from i want to say like
san diego or something
back to l.a i remember that that's i
remember being
and i was like i can't go to sleep i
have to [ __ ] stay awake
he's moving just in case yeah he's
moving that guy
doesn't waste any time yeah and he and
and without us
without george in the car i mean i've
talked to him on the phone
while he's on his way to the airport and
he's livid at people i mean he's
yeah road ragey but i love that guy he
think that's what that's
hard not to love i mean that means he's
dog he's just
oh you know one time one time i was uh
you know
i was really drunk and and uh we were in
uh
were we in new york we were a hotel yeah
because we were gonna be
canada the next night and um you know i
i
i went in on a man like having bad
breath and all this other [ __ ] like
hey man once you you know take a bath
and
[ __ ] brush your teeth and [ __ ] and
then the
the next morning i think i fired him
that night that night and then in the
morning
he was going to drive us to the airport
and you know
he was still on the clock he wishes well
you know and
and uh he's waving us off i apologize to
him for
did you remember that you had fired him
yeah yeah
but you know i'm gonna do that i rarely
well i guess i i guess i do apologize
when when i'm not wrong but i think i
was
i don't think i was wrong i just i just
think i was we were throwing down pretty
yeah i just think maybe i might have
went in too hard yeah yeah but did it
did it change him no but he's
he's a he's iconic as well he's like
i think if he wanted a tour manager that
was not stealing yeah because clearly
you can look at him and say this
[ __ ] is not stealing
yeah but also lives really
kind of uh and he was married no he's
married yeah
and then he says oh my wife's going to
pick me up one time
is this is this all going to make it i i
don't know we might have that but
anyways
so we we're at lax for doug's radio and
his
his old lady pulls up and gets out and
she's hot she's beautiful
yeah and kisses him on the mouth with
some breath
that could not stop a clock the
[ __ ] could unplug that
[ __ ]
yeah he won't be in but anyways yeah he
uh
god bless blessed but he's a god bless
him and everybody i think kind of
anybody in rock like around
you know and he's one degree from
everybody he knows everybody
you know doug knows like literally
everything jane's yeah
yeah yeah he's a good dude and everybody
loves him i mean every never see
you know so so so um doug doesn't drink
doug's never
drank doesn't doug's never smoked
um what what made you now you've been
you've been clean for you said 31 years
yeah
where were you before and then what what
was that point that
i mean you know i probably started it's
probably private but you know
you know the thing is i think the thing
with
rock man is like is it mandatory you
know like in knowing eddie you know
gotta level man and in the begin knowing
in the beginning that they were a band
trying to make it and then when you know
van halen one comes out
and then they're on the road that they
just started to just
just be they're legendary yeah
but what was the difference between like
when they were at the starwood or they
were at the whiskey
or any band that that makes it and then
when you make it
and you have some funds like you just go
out of your mind he and i
i did it well he and i did it but but
what what is that dude well the irony is
i never toured drunk
i always aspired to it you know and i
think
to to answer that question specifically
i think that
you know as i was growing up you know
and started drinking young like 12 13
you know and then smoking pot and then
doing when punk rock came is just like
every drug was available
in those clubs you know going to clubs
twice a week
you could get whatever you wanted and it
was great you know everything was fun
everything was just
it was great and then for me what
happened was
you know it it started to
become a habit you know and then i just
started doing it every day and then it
was like
i'd pass out and then i'd wake up and
then i'd drink first thing in the
morning and i'd drink all day
then i'd pass out and then i'd do it
again the last couple years were like
that
and you know i but i had always aspired
to
uh go on tour and i think because
to answer your question is you know you
you're once you start going on tour you
know it's like
you don't have to you know i was
aspiring to that moment when
i got a guy like doug looking after me
and all i got to do
i can sleep late and all i got to do is
really perform for an hour at night
i mean that in my limited view of what
really happens absolutely you know
you're not you don't know about press
and this and that
so it's like you know i was like i'll
get to sleep late
and i just have some dude wake me up and
tell me where to be and give me a piece
of paper that says you know
you'll be here at five o'clock and then
at 5 15 you go here right
and that was the dream right you know to
just and then play a show
and then pass out and then do it all
over again
but you know unfortunately it didn't
work out that way
and you know so for me i was still i was
uh
in a band with a guy that was that was
sober and
i was still working a tower video you
know my day job and i was in this band
and
and it just got really bad and you know
for me it was like every day i did
something that i never planned to do
um according to my own moral compass you
know
i was like oh i'm gonna steal some you
know i never woke up and said i'm gonna
crash my car today
yeah and i'm gonna cheat on my
girlfriend i'm gonna steal some stuff
from my mom to buy some drugs and i'm
gonna do
you know i never but i started doing all
that stuff you know
and being ashamed of it and then
drinking more and then like and it was
just this
spiral and then it just kept going and
kept going and kept going and
and then at the end you know i just
hated myself and
you know i i remember my last drink i
was sitting on my couch
and i had had alcohol poisoning your
last drink yeah i had alcohol poisoning
for like the
[ __ ] i don't know 20th time or
whatever yeah and uh
i was sitting on my couch and i was
holding this miller genuine draft
you know and i was like this and i knew
like this is the only thing in in the
world that's going to make me feel okay
you know but i couldn't keep it down
because i was so sick you know i was
like
gagging and trying i was taking little
sips of it and
i got like halfway done it took me like
an hour and i was just like
so sick and i just thought you know i
can't imagine
living the rest of my life this way but
i also can't imagine
not drinking for the rest of my life and
so i was at this impasse
and i called the guy i was in a band
with this guy john and i was like dude
you know i think i need to think i need
to get sober or whatever and he's like
he got all excited you know because we
were in a band together and he was like
in his first year
sober and i was just a train wreck you
know every day and
and um but but but as as you were kind
of a train wreck
did um people almost admire that like
oh this dude's [ __ ] crazy man like
this guy not at that point
that first you know when you're first
drinking and it's fun and like
everyone's
doing funny [ __ ] yeah and you know it's
fun but i was the guy when i
drank would like if i saw you
and we were friends and i saw you at a
club like in downtown
yeah i would [ __ ] get so excited to
see you that i would run as fast as i
could across the parking lot and i would
tackle you
you know and you're just like you're
there to like go out you might have a
girl with you and he's like hey what's
up
and you see this guy running at you full
speed like
hey what's up dude and then you're like
oh [ __ ] and i [ __ ] literally tackle
you
and then you're bleeding and you got a
big scrape on your elbow
you hit your head you know and you're
just like [ __ ] this guy and i would do
that [ __ ]
constantly in the last couple years of
drinking you know i would just
tackle people and and love on people way
too hard and
wow you know that's how i was and uh get
kicked out of places and banned from
places and
you know but i was never angry you know
i was just like oh
dude what's up you know i was like and
so uh
yeah and then then uh that's where i was
at and then i
and then this dude was like you know got
all excited and he's like all right dude
we're gonna go
you know we'll go to the thing and then
we'll uh
we're going to meetings yeah you know
like we'll go to a meeting and
uh you know and then uh
he he was like all right just don't
drink
today and i was like i already did and
he's like all right just go to sleep you
know that's like
i went to sleep and he woke up he's like
all right we'll go tomorrow and then he
took me you know
like i i started going and and uh
that was it that and just ever since you
know i just been
sober right i think the further you get
away from it like you know if you said
you know i already did
oh i did that and then the further you
get away from if you go a day without
drinking you go another day without
drinking
and the further you get away from it is
it the less that you
that you wanted you think i mean for me
honestly
i remember very clearly that you know
look you know when when you drink and do
a lot of drugs on a daily basis and you
constantly are uh
you know doing things that you're not
cool with and
you're you have all the shame and all
this stuff happens you feel like a
scumbag
and then you quit drinking and you feel
like a sober scumbag
and that's the thing that i had to that
that's where
you know what i got out of going to uh
these things that
i try and skirt around you know the the
way you know the things because it's
anonymous and whatever but you know and
but but um
but what i learned there was these tools
to kind of
deal with the fact that now i just feel
like a sober scumbag
you know what i mean i'm still feel like
that guy that did all those [ __ ] up
things
you know and how do i deal with that and
that's what i learned
and i felt kind of hopeless the thing
that i really got i don't know man
how do you how do you say you feel like
a sober scumbag but because because
because if some i've never heard anybody
say anything other than
i'm sober i never heard anybody say i'm
sober but
i feel like i'm depressed or i never put
i never
had anybody put an emotion behind i'm
sober
yeah and you just said i feel like a
sober skype well because you know and
when you're hitting bottom right and
you're you're really like going downhill
you know if you're if you're so bad to a
point where
you you stop you know you must feel
pretty [ __ ]
bad right right so and those things you
do
that's become your life i am the guy who
steals from my mom i am the guy that you
know she's
my girlfriend i am the guy that does all
these things
you don't necessarily go like oh well
it's just because i drink and now i
don't drink and now i'm normal
you know it's like you feel like you're
the guy that people don't want around
because you tackle them in the parking
lot you're the guy that never can pay
your rent you're the guy that
everyone's giving you the disapproving
head nod whenever they see you and
that's how you feel and all of a sudden
you take away the
drugs and alcohol you feel the same you
know until
you when i got sober they said to me
you never have to feel as hopeless as
you did the day before you you quit
drinking
again if you you know do the thing and
you
and and i haven't but you know it's like
i think some people you still yeah in
early sobriety it's like you you
for me it was like i felt kind of
hopeless you know and shitty all day and
then i would get these like little
windows of hope you know it'd be like oh
maybe it's going to be okay
maybe maybe maybe this is going to work
out maybe
you know i feel okay and then you start
thinking again and you're like oh
yeah but you're kind of a scumbag and
you know whatever it is and then
you would uh slowly start to
deal with the things and realize like
okay i'm not a scumbag it's just like i
did those things because i was drunk all
the time and those are really
that's not how i want to be or that's
not who i
am but those are things i did because i
was in a [ __ ] blackout
you know all day all the time you know
and so
so you slowly kind of learn uh
how to live sober basically because i
didn't know how to do
anything sober dude i didn't know how to
go on a date i didn't know how to be in
a relationship i didn't know how to go
to the market i didn't know how to
be bored i didn't know how to celebrate
i didn't know how to literally do
anything
sober because i didn't because i was
just drunk all day long every day
well i'm going to tell you something
i've never said before
that when i would meet somebody and i
would
go out with them i would say to myself
uh i'm good but i don't want them to see
me
drunk and times we'd go out and i would
get drunk
and get way drunk and that's what i
didn't want them to see
but they saw it early because i couldn't
help not going out and being drunk and
then that person would
would remove themselves but i tried but
there was no way that i was going to be
successful at it because
every time i went out i got [ __ ]
hammered yeah so
i would say oh this girl's great man you
know i just don't want her to see
the drunk me yeah and she would right
away if not the first
time you know the second time yeah yeah
i mean you know
so in your years though it's been well
don't say it like you weren't with me
you know right yeah so yeah yeah i mean
he's just saying like oh no i got but
you know you know what i mean and i and
i knew man i knew if i really liked
somebody that i would say
oh you know not i hope that
just make sure you're like and i i
couldn't help it
yeah i couldn't help it yeah i mean you
do all those things to try and like
time it out right or you know like well
if i eat a bunch
before i go on the date and then i don't
i don't drink beforehand or whatever
yeah hold it off for a minute you know
it's but for me it was just like
uh for me personally it's just like i
never understood
social justice but i mean you know
i i don't think there is social i mean
if somebody's gonna say uh
social drinking but you know um
not the way we drink i mean like you
said social drinking is like a couple
drinks and you're like hey goodnight
everybody
but it's like that dude it's like you
know you drank it like you're not you're
not
five in and you're not just like you
know like
him i just pointed to him yeah yeah but
you know what i mean but you guys are
like
you know like kind of together and it's
not like
yeah i did i [ __ ] love you man you're
[ __ ]
great man i think you're the best you
know like oh man i love you
so in those three decades though have
you like said earlier you're going to
meetings early
do you still yeah tap into that yeah all
the time
yeah i mean i mean for me you know it's
like
and it's a lot of uh
you know uh i remember someone saying to
me like
you know someone was like oh you don't
need to still go to meetings you you
know you're good blah blah and i'm like
you know it's like this other thing i
heard this old timer say like
yeah but what if i cut out the wrong
thing you know
what if i cut out the wrong me what if i
cut out like the thing and
and i've had experience where you know
i've had some time and stopped going to
to stop doing the things that i did in
my first year that really like
helped me and you know and the the
my head got really loud and i felt kind
of you know kind of nuts
and wanted to you know wanted some
relief
from how i started feeling a little nuts
and
you know then i just went back and
started doing the same things and felt
so
so when you were with yourself and uh
i think you'll understand this yes when
you were with yourself
did you not feel you were alone because
you know
you know when you drank you could wake
up in the morning go man i was really
[ __ ] tore up
uh last night i could take it i can take
a shower and i can kind of drink coffee
and i can try to eat or get right
you're almost having an internal
dialogue with yourself to kind of make
it
okay but it's not okay right i think
when people wake up and they're hungover
like what we did like yeah you know we
don't we're on the road and we call each
other up in this place call each other
go
you know in the afternoon like how are
you and it's like oh i struggle in the
morning and stuff like that but
but i think for me it was different
though because i never
felt like that i always was like i wake
up
and i would be either still drunk
or a little hungover okay because i
never really got super hungover
i just went straight to alcohol
poisoning like you know i can't drink
for
two days and i'm puking up foam and and
whatever
but i just woke up and
i was like okay i need a drink you know
that's that for me that's where i was
like the last couple years was just like
you know saint eyed said just come out i
remember i worked at tower video dude
and the only
liquor store on this side of like
washington boulevard that sold st
ice was right across the street from me
they sold cisco
they sold sainides and that's where i
would go
and you know i would just drink the next
day i would
drink a couple beers before i went to
work and then i would drink you know and
before tower video yeah but was that
related to
what what did you related now that
you've been sober so long
what was that related to was it really
alcoholism okay
i i don't know was it related to to
growing up was it related to
it was just related to just being drunk
i think so dude like
because you know i've talked to
different people because you know
somebody said oh you know
this happened or like childhood trauma
exactly like as much as i talked [ __ ]
about my childhood
it wasn't it wasn't bad yeah you know
i drank with those dudes at 13. i'm
still friends with a lot of the guys
we go out you know and we have a good
time it wasn't because you know maybe i
didn't know my mom or my dad
i i wasn't off the hook i didn't you
know
really do a lot it was just fun kind of
just the way it was yeah
same with me i drank because it was like
you know when i when i started drinking
it wasn't like
you know i've heard a lot of people have
that experience where it's like oh i
finally felt comfortable in my own skin
and i finally was like everything was
okay and then i was
but for me it was like oh this is fun
you know that this is
like everything's a little more fun a
little looser blah blah
and i just went from there and i think
that you know there's kind of this maybe
imaginary line between hard drinker and
alcoholic that
you never see you know and i just and
not even to say if i knew where it was i
would stop there
i'd probably just blow past it you're
like oh whatever yeah yeah i'll be fine
and you know but for me there was like
my parents
got divorced when i was young but my dad
was always around
he lived in the oakwood apartments like
two blocks away
and he would take me to school every day
still and he was like came to every show
i ever played and
you know was there though we would the
whole time like you know like
we i'd stay at his house once a week and
my mom got remarried and then
you know got remarried again later but
and my stepdad i got along with great
that's like
it was just because i think i crossed
the line and
i just bought both straight when you
performed you didn't perform
you weren't high when you performed i
mean i was when i was drinking
when i was drinking i did everything did
you do drugs dude
yeah i i drank i
i had you know it's like that thing i
said you know i played a guitar
and you know like recorded it on acid
there was other stuff like when i was in
that band that i was like kind of
hitting bottom yeah and my buddy was
sober
i was uh i remember we would go to san
diego all the time and play
and and i would like to coke and stay up
all night and then
the next day i would play and i would
still be on coke and and drinking and
and i and i was like you know shredding
i was like
awesome you know like and then i would
hear recordings of it afterwards and i
was like
it was horrible yeah like so bad but in
the moment though
like we we've known musicians who played
drunk
every single gig they had and then when
they were sober they tripped because
like people were looking at me was was
it more fun to play
when you were hammered or when you were
sober knowing that this is it
i'm in the moment because we've had
people say the eye i don't know you know
like you went to the us festival you saw
van halen there right yeah
so so the the le the legend of
of that they got paid a million five
yeah
but that david lee roth was drunk which
i i it doesn't look like it but that ed
was uh
ed played great and i don't think ed i
don't think eddie
was a drinker as much as he maybe
was into this into the uh into the
drought
i don't want to save man got you know so
i would just say
that ed was never sloppy in that time
that he that even seeing that he played
great
yeah and they said that dave was drunk
but they sounded [ __ ] they sounded
great
yeah but whatev whatever it just became
a part of every musician's ritual
of of doing things right yeah yeah so in
the moment
which would you would you think you're
killing it when you're high
even though it sounded like [ __ ] later
but did was it more fun to play higher
or sober
i guess when i'm massively never fight's
over no no you played sober after i mean
yeah i think that it was
probably more fun to play when i was
drinking because it was more
look if i'll be honest you know it's
like if a
if a a genie
came out of this beer can and said i'll
grant you three wishes i guarantee you
one of them would be i want to be able
to drink
and do stuff the way i used to and not
have my life fall apart
you know what i mean because to me it's
like to me drinking is like driving you
know it's like
uh driving is a privilege that you earn
you prove to the state like i'm
confident
i'm competent to drive this six thousand
pound piece of metal around the streets
you know and and uh you screw up too
many times and they take the privilege
away
and for me that's how i look at drinking
like i just abused the [ __ ] out of it
and and it got taken away you know
unfortunately but
did i enjoy it would i love to be able
to do it
you know with impunity and not have it
ruin my life at all sure if if i could
but i can't because i know that if i
drink if i
if i drank here i would have to uber
home
because i'd say like oh what are you
guys doing after the show you know what
i would [ __ ]
because i know myself and i know that by
the time
you know six o'clock rolled around i
would be throwing up
in the bathroom and you know i'd go home
and pass out
i have to hide it from my wife and kids
sure and then the next day
i would wake up with a hangover and i'd
go down to sportsman's lodge until i can
start drinking
awesome okay so so um
you when where did you how did you meet
your can i ask how you met your wife and
joey castillo
his his wife no his girlfriend at the
time
owned this uh this shoe boutique called
diavelina that was on um
that was in hollywood joey
said to me dude i know this girl you i
think she works at every shop you're
gonna love this girl you know and i was
like oh
what's her deal and she's like oh he
goes uh
i think she lives with her ex-boyfriend
but they're broken up and
like she still goes out with other
people but i think they're i was like
dude i don't want to i don't even want
to meet her you know i don't want
anything to do with it because it sounds
like a bunch of drama to me
and then a year later uh joey and his
girlfriend at the time
uh their birthdays were at the same time
so they had this joint birthday party at
the belmont our buddies um restaurant on
la cienega
and where's that the belmont like
los cienega between santa monica and uh
melrose
it's still there yeah no yeah it is i
think it is i'm
sure it is yeah but uh yeah so we so and
then he's like oh that's the girl i was
telling you about
you know at the at the bar and she was
with like her brother
and five friends so i was like oh no
it's cool i don't want to meet her you
know it's like i'm
gonna [ __ ] walk up in the middle of
the girl hey hell it's nice to meet you
and so i just was like oh whatever and
then i at some point we
we met and then i walked away
and then we did the kind of like the
look back you know with the little
the eyes meeting yeah yeah and uh
and that was it the next day i called uh
joey's
girlfriend and i said hey you know can i
get
can you ask that girl chris if i can get
her number because i want to you know
take her out
and then we ended up you know i ended up
going out with her and
and uh that was it dude we we uh
and we started dating like
i think three months before i got
involved revolver
and uh beautiful yeah it was great and
we've been together ever since
and uh did you have uh other
relationships with the girls that you
you know that were long term or were you
in love
i think yeah i've had other but i think
the longest relationship
ever was like a couple years maybe
but you know i never i remember getting
past like the four-year mark with my
wife
did you think that did you think that
the way you grew up
that were you not connected to people or
connected to women
or you were but they were like when you
were drinking
i was always into the the i've always
been like a softy in that way and been
like into the monogamous
relationship and like you know like i'm
just gonna have one girlfriend i
couldn't like
like i knew dudes that were like sport
[ __ ] girls and i was like i can't do
it i just too much of a conscience dude
i'd just be like oh i feel bad
you know and and maybe when you're drunk
and you go through periods where you're
like
you have one night stands or you can
pull it off or you're single whatever
but i just i just was always into
like that was my dream you know my dream
was like someday i'm gonna meet a cool
chick
i'm gonna get a little house i'm like a
two-bedroom house
and i want to be able to eat out like
nothing fancy like
puyoloco or whatever you know i just
want to be able to
you know eat out when i want and meet
some cool chick
and maybe you know have some kids
someday and
have a little house right like that was
my dream yeah you know
then and and uh yeah that was there you
go
yeah how old are your kids uh my son
will be
13 next month so 12 and 11 11 and 12.
yeah my daughter just turned 11.
musically uh inclined or it's so funny
dude
we've been forcing my son to
play guitar he takes lessons once a week
we
just stop the lessons like he for
over a year he's played every instrument
he's had lessons
playing guitar then he did drums and he
did bass and he did the rock band thing
at school where they'd be in a band
they'd learn a song
and he just uh
he's weird because anything that he
picks up he gets
you know he's good at it he's good at
everything
but he's just not that into it you know
what i mean he's just not
into playing like he could play it the
even the guitar pl teacher was like
he can get it but he won't he just never
practiced sure you know but he can
play a chord and he can do this he can
do that so so so when you have your kids
and you know
everything that we talked about do you
do you think back to
the family in iowa do you do you think
about all that like your lineage back
i do i do it's it's funny because when i
was on tour
you know i remember we played in des
moines and
my grandmother still lives there and my
aunt
and uh and this big extended family
she's like 60 50 60 people
uh all the valdez's and the tauruses
and uh and you know they they all
are like these three are cops and these
three you know are
the own a business and then whatever and
uh
and it's weird man because it's like uh
i remember going back
and you know my aunt was like oh they're
gonna we're having a party
you know like and it was just like this
[ __ ]
i mean you know it is it's just like
it's
amazing you know it's just like
everyone's like hey
you know like how do you do what's up
you know it's just like everyone's all
happy to see you and and
talking about you like you've been there
the whole time and just like
loving on you and it was incredible you
know and
you know and then i kind of stayed in
touch with some of the
you know extended family the cousins and
stuff and then
you know but i haven't gone back a lot
and and
i haven't gone back with my kids and now
my
uh and then my grandmother's you know
she's pretty
she's [ __ ] 90 something now she's
i don't know if she's gonna be around
much longer and and
what sucks about you know the the the
virus and everything is
you know i thought about flying out
there yeah you know but
i haven't and you know i think i'm
always a little
conflicted you know about it to be
honest yeah yeah
you know some days i'm like oh i should
do this i should do that
and then i get caught up in my life and
and i don't
well you know i i uh you know i was born
at general hospital
i didn't know my father i didn't know my
mother my grandparents raised me
um my grandfather wasn't biological but
in creating you know my identity through
through my culture and through uh
you know uh the clubs in the 80s and
then
i'm meeting arsenio and then doing you
know
white crying and all that stuff about
the parties in the backyard and all that
stuff that
brought you know me success and all that
and then the show and all this stuff but
um you know uh
i would be considered the ultimate
chicano
uh in l.a but as the ultimate chicano i
just want to tell you matt that i'm
proud of
who you are and what you became thanks
man
that means a lot yeah that's cool right
yeah it means a lot to me too emotional
yeah well it's you know it's a it's a
i think it's a deep rooted thing you
know what i mean when you when you
really
kind of you know and it's like i admire
you the way you've
kind of connected so deeply with your
own culture
and it's something that you know i i
wish i was
had done more of you know and it's like
it's
it's funny you know because well i
laughed this year
but i left this year i laugh because you
know in the last four years it's like
then you've got
this this my last name's kushner and
just like yeah and then sometimes people
are like oh any relationship
or it's almost like i have to say it
first you know and like say oh no
relation
and there was a time where uh
i like 25 years ago or something i had
put back my mom's made a name into my
name yeah so it was dave torres kushner
yeah you know just to
to kind of honor that side you know
that's what my tattoo right here says
torres and
so and believe me if any time you know
recently i'm like
oh maybe i need to put that back in yeah
yeah like you know um
for me to be able to recreate those
backyard parties where they're like
uh also you couldn't even bring ice you
know somebody shows up and they
didn't eat everything yeah tho those
were the things that
that made me uh
proud to be a chicano but all the [ __ ]
that you we
we've been talking about these last two
hours
make me prouder peachy color thanks man
so yeah that means a lot because
i miss those party you know it's like
and that's what was the great thing
about when i was drinking you know
because it was like
like when i grew up for instance you
know i grew up in in
you know i guess it's korea town now but
it wasn't korea down then
and it was like you know it was where
was it
uh first in vermont right where virgil
junior high is like
i lived around the corner from virgil
yeah and it was like
like when i grew up dude it was there
was no i had one white friend
his name was timmy he was had red hair
he had a hook
yeah he had a look yeah with no armor
one of his arms
literally had one of those hooks like
this you know and and he had well he had
red hair and freckles
and i swear to god that was my only
white friend growing up because everyone
was either black
or chinese or mexican you know and it
was great
you know that was like how i grew up
like being part of the chinese new year
parade because my friend's
dad was part of that or whatever it was
that's how i got into like my first
music i was ever into was earth wind and
fire
uh you know sliding the family stone all
those bands the
brothers johnson because because my best
friend was black and his
he had two older brothers and that's all
they listened to stevie wonder
all that [ __ ] was like that's like in my
house that's what i listen to now most
of the time because it's like
marvin gaye all that stuff because it's
it's so
you know ingrained in me listen man you
know
uh i was the only child my grandfather
who wasn't biological
his his nephew worked at a record
pressing plan in van nuys so he would
always come and visit
you know his uncle whatever that you
know it wasn't related to me but i would
and he would bring misprinted
albums and this is from like um
the early 70s uh songs of kia live
captain fantastic um total
uh uh although all all of these records
that
i had in junior high before anybody had
them
and um
sit back in that room over there and
[ __ ]
hager street with a little record player
and be playing these things that were
knockoffs
just like i have a love of music that
nobody really knows but was that the
beginning of it
i'm not sure but really [ __ ] amazing
[ __ ] man to be able to sit back there
and hear
songs of the key of life when eddie and
i
you know would play golf and i told him
that the first time i heard
van halen won and i put it on my record
player and i heard the the the [ __ ]
horn that i ran to the window and looked
at the window because i thought somebody
was outside
and he's like no man we did that you
know [ __ ] horns man and i [ __ ]
thought something was going on outside
that that my whole education kiss
and all of that stuff ted nugent and all
you know for ted and i are friends and
everybody like hey that [ __ ]
republican it's like you know what man
i'm into the music man yeah
and that cat's always been great too the
guys i went to high school with remember
to go see him
yeah [ __ ] so it's not politics man
it's like no
music is music and that's the thing you
know like so
what well that's what i was saying is
like so and then when i
when when i i moved to dc for
arlington virginia when i was 10 and
that was a culture shock for me
because there was no it was all what
there was
i went to how does an element
so my mom got remarried when i was like
five and then
uh when i was 10 my my step dad got a
job at the white house
when jimmy carter was an oh my god i was
in the inauguration parade oh my gosh
when jimmy carter got uh elected
because they're like oh well we need a
mexican kid on the float
you know what i mean like it was kind of
like a float and i remember i saw a
picture of it dude i have a rams beanie
on
and they're like i'm like oh i'm only
half mexican
yeah they put me on the float in the in
the uh
you didn't go to the inauguration at the
kennedy center did you you didn't
no no no it was just like a parade some
parade
and i sat in a like a hay ride you know
with a bunch of other kids oh that's
amazing you know and
but it was it was a culture shock for me
because there was no
there was two black girls in my whole
elementary school
that was it dude everyone was white and
that for me was like
wait this is weird and then i came back
when i was 12
because my parents got divorced my dad
my stepdad stayed there he still lives
there
and me and my mom came back and then we
went we lived in the same house back on
vermont and then that's when i started
going to bancroft
and you know then it was like
i had again and then when i was drinking
and hanging out with the joey and all
those dudes it was like
it was just like when i was a kid you
know it was like everyone was yeah
all different races all different you
know it was
it was [ __ ] like this guy's italian
and that guy's you know mexican and
that guy's black it was just like a big
melting pot and
it was those kind of parties like you
know like oh i'm gonna go down to
you know i'm going to this butcher and
getting like carne asada and
you know like all this stuff in there
did you have uh was gil sedillo in your
band
no ones no you never had horns in your
i don't know i don't know that guy oh
because he i thought i heard that maybe
you got that horns in your
you never had a batman who has a batman
horns in those times
no but no i did i remember when i was in
the love hogs we had a
uh we uh tommy lee produced
part of our first record about that 1990
that's amazing yeah
man because uh so our band's kind of
was kind of like faith no more like that
vibe yeah yeah i'm sure
and uh uh the guy tom zut who signed
motley and guns and roses at geffen he
uh i guess at the time tommy was looking
for a band to produce
and uh somehow he came to check us out
and he liked us because we were kind of
like funk and metal and like all these
things that he was into
and uh and then we we uh
geffin offered us a demo deal you know
where they give you like 15 grand to do
three songs yeah and we were like we
don't want a demo deal we wanted like a
straight up record deal and
i remember tom was like well if you guys
tommy's really pissed if you don't do
the demo you know thing then he's not
going to want to be a part of it and
we're like
really and then we find out later like
he was like no dude
i'll i'll purdue you know you want to do
this record he didn't care
so then uh he ended up producing a few
songs on our record
and it was it was incredible but he but
we had a this guy fernando that had
played with uh
a later version of earth wind and fire
played uh
horns on one of the sections it was
killer
like being in the studio watching you
know someone
record horns and really like knowing
what they did and
it was incredible here's the ultimate
question of uh
of any rock person uh were you into thin
lindsay or
or was that yeah yeah because i was
always into uh
any any any [ __ ] rock person
that you meet and you say hey dude were
you into thin lindsay and if they say
yes
like you're in a group of [ __ ]
that are like almost like uh they're
illuminati
get ready a made man all right well it's
gary moore dude
that dude is just like he's unbelievable
i mean i was like in the like his solo
records and
there's this uh song called end of the
world where it's like
this there's certain you know guitar
solos where you hear it where it just
makes you want to like
run your head through a wall because
it's just like so
deep emotion like that's how i feel with
the
so that's a dude gary moore's a dude
that nobody talks about as a [ __ ]
great guitar player
well you're talking about the greatest
guitar players but one of the best right
all time because it's just like you know
okay so there's a song uh
electric eye right the judas priest song
when you listen to that solo in that
song
it just sounds like the [ __ ]
fretboard like tearing apart
it's just like it sounds like he's
struggling
so hard to [ __ ] squeeze these notes
out and when i would listen to gary
moore
that's how it sounds like to me you know
it's like it's just like there's so much
and and how is it possible man how can a
guy
how does the guy do that why is the
fretboard
or the ability for somebody to how is
one dude that much better than everybody
else bro i don't know because
what what's right what's even weirder to
me is that
they're not oh like gary moore is not
like that in every song
and glenn tipton was not like that in
every solo that
he did in judah's priest there's just
like this moment you know and i don't
know if it's
divine intervention or what it is but
it's like for me i just
hear that moment because it's like you
know it's like the first time you do
a certain drug and then you're always
chasing that right high
it's like for me it's like i'm always
chasing that solo and i listen to other
judas priest songs i'm like
nah so so older than you guys
at the santa monica civic we go see
robin trower
[ __ ] amazing underrated underrated
um and then we we saw
i saw [ __ ] thin lizzy live and
dangerous
at the santa monica uh civic
um and it sounded like
live and dangerous does anyone here have
any irish anymore
and it it was
so unbelievable man and i went with all
the guys
i was in high school with yeah and
phil had the black pants he had the
white thing he had the base up high
i mean just amazing man like [ __ ]
so if all of all the concerts that i've
seen i've seen everybody that
that then lizzie is the is the
kevin bacon of six degrees of separation
you know they always go
yeah you know i saw a growl over there
and i said hey uh
or morello over there in the burbank
airport with thomas and lindsey and
just like anybody who who who rocks
then lizzie's like yeah the the
the band what's like yeah i mean
even with gary moore though dude like i
would listen to thin lizzy and try and
hear that thing i heard in that
song you know and i don't hear it as
much and though you know it's like
it's more it was it's a little like the
like reserved they were a little bit
they were a little bit [ __ ] jazzy man
thinly was a little bit
the boys were back in town that's right
but a lot of the slaves are still
dancing the moonlight it's kind of
steely dan
you know what i mean it's like the
steely rock yeah
now is there a solo like like you were
talking about the other guys who just
nailed it is there one of your own that
you go oh yeah
that's my uh that's
that's the one of my own yeah
yeah i would say that when i did that
record that uh
electric love hogs record there's a song
called tribal monkey which was the
the the single yeah and i did a solo in
there that i really
is probably my favorite and that's the
one you're like i was in the moment
that's like
yeah yeah for me and and when you think
back on that solo when you're recording
it were you thinking anything or was
that just like a
just art no i don't you know you just
like i said you just
you do what you do and it's like great
art i think like my i remember
my mom's third husband he's like you
know
i just show up every day he was a
painter he's like i show up every day
and
and you know you just show up enough
times and once in a while something
great
shows up too you know it's just who
knows when it's going to show up
but that's the thing you know because if
it just showed up great all the time it
wouldn't be
that's special you know so so um
what were you gonna do man you you were
gonna do said decker what were we gonna
oh yeah yeah i was gonna so
so when let's ask the proper question
well
ask him the proper question and and so
we're getting well yeah
so it's not all fantastic it's very
important exactly we i
i believe that you wanted to join a set
builders union what do you mean i
believe [ __ ] you didn't even
know
i had heard that wait a minute why
didn't you just ask him i heard you
because on a podcast on another podcast
i heard you talk about the fact that you
want to be
the longest set builders union hang on a
second
hey greg how many of these have we done
okay you know what man in ten in
ten [ __ ] episodes like you have not
gotten better at asking a [ __ ]
question i have not managed to get of a
guy who
i mean how long we've been talking
[ __ ] like 10 30
at night
[ __ ] nine hours going through this
question in my head
the whole two hours no kidding uh so
i think he wants you to ask about the
beginning of no no bolver you know what
man no
no i was gonna get it you know what
because there's always a fork in the
road in somebody's life
where you either do or you don't i think
that's
an impasse if you will how far you see
well that's why it's not
right oh my god it's not because i'm a
universal figure
ask him in everyone's life
there seems to be a fork in the road
there's like an impasse if you will if
you will there's a doer you don't
there was a there's a did or didn't do i
go buy a hammer or do i
right or do i pick up this ass tell us
about your history in
art department on sets that's so awful
man
i'm not sure well yeah i would rephrase
the question like
at some point you have to decide whether
you continue with
what you need to do or what you love uh
here's what happened
so uh
so it had to be at a point where it's a
little bit down right
well what happened was uh
so when i did that zilch gig right i did
that thing in japan
i uh we did it he's just trying to
include you to make you
yeah it's really cool right here
he could just beat me
oh my god dude what is this cilantro you
speak of okay i'm sorry
uh but when i was in japan yes but it's
it's life-changing
when i was in japan uh we did a gig
with duff's band right and he and i
didn't really know each other
we um we kind of uh we bonded
neither one of us was drinking we uh
we hung out we became friends after that
and we went on to
become friends in a very non-musical way
like he he's a big reader and he would
read all these books and he'd be like
dude i just read this book
uh you know called black hawk down and
they made a movie out of it we should go
see this movie and we'd go and like go
to the movies together and just like
hang out
you know and then i started playing with
him
and then the uh not velvet revolver but
um randy castillo died right
drummer from ozzie's band matt wanted to
i remember being in swingers on beverly
and duff and i were eating
and matt came in and said you know hey
i'm thinking about throwing this benefit
for randy's family for to pay for all
the you know
the the fees and you know the the
funeral and everything
and he wasn't talking to me he was
talking to duff you know about like
because he lived right around the corner
from swingers uh
matt did and they he was talking about
and
he ended up getting like slash and duff
and matt back together which is the
first time they had played together in
years
and then the two the singer and the
guitar player from buck cherry
and steven tyler and all these dudes got
back together and
played you know a bunch of covers at the
key clip for randy's
thing then that's kind of how velvet
revolvers started
they they thought you know this feels
good let's let's do this with uh
with the two guys from buck cherry they
started
uh i was doing something with duff at
the time and then
he he called me i remember and he was
like hey i'm going to check out this
vote this
other thing and i don't know if i'm
going to have time to do that other
thing and i was like oh
god i was so bummed dude and i was just
like oh that's cool you know
that's good good for you it was great
and uh
and i was i was working on sets building
sets at the time
and um doing art department stuff and
i was like [ __ ] i'm gonna i gotta uh
it's 2 500 bucks to join the union
set builders union and so i i was
about to ask my dad and then
i kind of just kept going and then duff
they only did it for like a month or two
and they were they were writing songs
with
the those guys and duff you know where
and i were talking a lot
and he said um he's like oh it's not
gonna work out with the singer you know
it's just not
so we're gonna we're gonna get rid of
him and and you know we got this other
guitar player guy
and then he called me a couple weeks
later and he was like hey you know what
i think we're going to get uh we're
going to move on from this other guy too
he's like we've written like eight songs
i'm going to give you these songs and
you should come down and
play and i was like okay cool uh
wow he's like i think i'm gonna we're
gonna get rid of them next week
you know we're gonna we're gonna i think
it's not gonna work out
uh we're gonna we're gonna part ways
next week i said okay cool
he gives me the eight songs he calls me
and he says hey man
um did you learn any of those songs
cause uh we ended up
just firing him today and we want you to
come down tomorrow this was like the
next day and i'm like oh
[ __ ] and like uh okay yeah cool
you know like all right cool he's like
do you know any kinds of roses songs i'm
like no
and he goes all right well maybe you
should try and learn you know whatever
it was brownstone or what
right so i'm like okay cool and this is
all like what i
think happened you know it's like what
pretty much what i remember
sure and then um the next day i went
down
and you know i'd known slash since
junior high so i was comfortable around
him
and duff i had been playing with off and
on for you know
nine months to a year i was comfortable
around him matt i had known just from
around
so you know back to like was it a lot of
pressure
not really because i was already kind of
comfortable you know
like and and i i really just came in and
i brought all my pedalboard
my weird things and i just set it all up
and i was like all right cool let's
play and and i don't know dude then
they said you know i was and we were
done and i was going to pack up my [ __ ]
and
yeah you know they're like oh you could
just leave it and i was like oh
okay you know and and like why don't you
come back tomorrow and like let's
jam some more and i was like okay and
you know i left and you know i was
stoked but
i didn't know what any of it meant
because there was no band really and it
was like
and i still had to work and i was still
like you know gonna join the union and
and so i was getting ready to borrow
that money and then i
i had asked my dad you know already and
he was like yeah you can borrow the
money
and i just kind of held off on it you
know i was like well let's see what
happens
and it was a really weird
10 months because i never they never
said you're in the band
you know they never were like all right
dude you're in here's your check or what
you know whatever
because it wasn't even really a band yet
it was just like but we
and then we would record uh we write
songs five days a week
you know duff and slash footed the bill
for the rehearsal place
we show up and then i would get afraid
that if i took a job
on a movie or or a music video or
whatever that i would lose my spot
so i wasn't taking any jobs and so i
actually asked bobby the guy who owned
mates rehearsal
if he would give me a job that way i
could be there
because we would rehearse from two to
six so i'm like well if i work here at
mates
then i'd work like nine to two and he
knew
everyone and he was like why don't you
work nine to two
then you'll be here at two you can go to
rehearsal and you can do cartage and
whatever so i was like all right cool
and
and i that's what i did and you know
then the rest is it took 10 months
though like
before we got scott and we got going and
then
you know up until the very last minute i
was just like
i gotta remember i remember we were
recording
we got scott in the band we were
recording uh
the first thing we ever recorded was a
song for
um the italian job we did a cover of
money by pink floyd
and then we did our first original song
for the
end credits for the hulk movie the
angley one with eric banner
yeah and uh i remember we were in this
studio on
highland and we're recording the song
and it was like midnight
i was like [ __ ] dude i i remember matt
being in the room and i'm like dude i
gotta go
he's like what what where do you gotta
go i'm like i gotta i'm gonna
like roadie for my friend's band they're
playing craig kilbourne and i gotta be
at
hurts rent-a-car and get a van at six in
the morning and then
take all their gear to the show you know
at seven and
he's like he's like dude you're in a
rock but yeah man
you know he's like you're in a rock band
now you don't need to [ __ ]
i'm like dude i didn't get we haven't
gotten any checks yet we haven't gotten
any money yet
you know i'm [ __ ] going because
that's 200 bucks cash
yeah you know what i mean so i'm like
wow and that's what i did until
i got the first check you know and i was
like
you know i don't know that's just what
you do i guess
unless you don't how did the um sunset
manicure thing happen
and you started to do that stuff so the
whole band happened
you know we made two records uh we ended
up firing scott
at one point because the band just got
very separated
you know and uh and so we fired him in
april and my son
was born uh a month later
right so i had a kid he was super
colicky
like he just it was inconsolable for the
first year
basically and it was just like drove us
crazy and
uh so the band you know we looked for a
singer for like a year
you know we looked for different singers
we had a guy for a minute
that didn't work out we tried out the
guy from space hog we tried out this guy
uh this other guy ian thornley we there
was talks of
lenny kravitz being interested like we
there was a lot of
you know for a year but at the same time
i was like i don't have a job
you know and right luckily i had saved
all my money you know i was a partner in
the band so i really
like i wasn't a hired guy you know and i
and i had a piece of everything and i
just saved all my money because
at that point i was you know 13 years
sober when the band started
i had been around i was old enough to
know like this could all
fall apart tomorrow so i'm just going to
save whatever i can
and so um luckily i was i was in a good
position and you know i was like at this
impasse
again you know kind of like what am i
going to do you know i don't i don't
want to be a hired guy
if i leave my wife's going to go crazy
because this
kid's out of his mind you know and like
not really but you know like what i
can't leave her
you know and uh so i just decided like
what
what could i do you know i could maybe i
could produce stuff even though i hadn't
really done much of that
or i was interested in composing you
know for my
my best friend was a composer
and i just asked him like what do you do
how do you do it you know and he's like
and and it was interesting because both
of them said
the guy who produced the first bell
revolver record i had grown up with as
well
and i was like and i just asked them
kind of like you know methodically like
how did you do that how did you do that
and they were they both said the same
thing
that was interesting was like you have
to commit to it
and not take other gigs and kind of get
into the mindset that this is what i'm
gonna do now
and i i
would did it and finally i was like yeah
okay that's what i'm gonna do
and uh i swear to god i just i got
really lucky and
and i was at johnny rockets with a few
friends of mine
uh and one of them rockets johnny
rockets is like a diner like
which one oh uh the one at a farmer's
market
okay so i was there with uh
my buddy scott who plays base in weezer
my buddy brian ray who plays with uh
paul mccartney and this guy bob
uh who was ended up being the composer
on sons of anarchy
so we're all there uh eating and bob
says
hey you know um i'm working on this new
show
and they didn't really start filming it
but it's kind of like the sopranos meets
the hell's angels
and blah blah and you know it's i think
it's really gonna be a cool show and i'm
the you know music supervisor and the
composer and
you know if you got any ideas and i said
oh you should get bands like
i started throwing out all these band
names like monster magnet would be cool
and clutch and this band and that band
he's like oh really that's cool
so we just it started you know it was
flowing like this and and and
he was like uh if you want to come over
and write something
that'd be cool i have a studio you know
blah blah and i was like and this was
like
another big thing for me was my head is
wired to say no
out of fear you know like to everything
well you know what i mean wait a minute
that
we we talked about that that that really
uh
if you want to talk about being a
[ __ ] chicano
our heads are wired to say no initially
like if you go tomorrow the guy's going
to give you a thousand dollars now
yeah yeah exactly i'm not going to go my
my life change because everything was no
to me
yeah and even the guy said are you on
your way and i said no
like what's gonna you know what are they
gonna do for me and i went
but our you what you just said was just
dead on
yeah is that our heads are wired to say
no yeah yeah
exactly and this was that's why for me
this was such a big moment because
i i wanted to say no but i said yes
you know because i also learned from
going to meetings and doing all that
stuff was like contrary action like you
know
what say yes you know like you you never
whatever you know and and i and
because i in my head you know i'm wired
to think like
oh i'm not really good enough i don't
blah blah blah blah blah blah
and he's like really good and i'm not
really good and he's older than me
and so i said all right cool yeah and
he's like all right well why don't you
come over you know next week and i said
okay cool you know and terrified
really if i'm honest you know of course
and so
dude but i i had uh you know
i was a big fan of this one shooter
jennings who's a friend of mine he had
written this record
and he there was this one song called
this old wheel and i i love this song
and i was like and i was talking to
shooter and i was like dude we should do
something together and i'd love to blow
did just
and i'd come up with this riff in my
head thinking of shooter jennings
and i went to bob's and i was like oh
dude i have this riff
you know and it was that burning
and he was like oh that's cool and we
literally we wrote the whole song
in a couple hours because it was a theme
song so it doesn't have to be
three and a half minutes it's you know
30 seconds or whatever
yep and you know i had that that part
and we recorded
like a demo of it that day with him
singing on it and we wrote the lyrics
and
he sang on it and he wrote the melody
and we
had a whole song that day and then you
know
but it was like the band dude it was
like we wrote the song
and then we kept trying i called shooter
i'm like hey you want to sing on this
song and he's like ah
i don't know and he wasn't into it
because he didn't
have any part writing in it you know and
so
and then we tried like different guys
and we we finally we got this guy curtis
steiger's who crushed it you know and
uh but we didn't
they didn't decide it was gonna be the
theme song for like nine months
and the funny thing is that bob would
get these emails from fox
that would say like hey what if what if
the theme song was like
slash and lemmy or what if the theme
song was
like stone temple pilots like they kept
trying to go out to like people i knew
and i was in a band with
and we just waited it out dude and nine
months later literally
we went to a screening a premiere you
know they would do that like a paramount
course
the pilot episode and literally that
week they said you know we think we're
going to use this
as a theme song and we're literally
we're sitting in
[ __ ] the studio of paramount you know
in that theater they have there
in the lot and we watched it and we were
like that's the first time we saw it
with the opening credits and we were
like
oh [ __ ] this is this is it dude like
this is gonna be the theme song
and that was it dude and then we got
nominated for an emmy for writing that
theme song and
that changed the whole course of my life
you know it was like i called
my agent and i was like at caa because
the band was a ca
i'm like i think i want to be a composer
you know i think i i got some traction
now i got this i want to parlay this and
to do it i want to do this you know and
and that was it and then i started doing
it and then that guy bob
uh was a was a music supervisor on this
abc
show called detroit187 which is like a
cop drama
and i i didn't know what i was doing
like as far as scoring or
i didn't know how to do all that and you
know he's like hey you and john
my best friend growing up he's like if
you guys want to do this you should
you know send some demos in and blah
blah you know demo for it
and we got that job and that's where i
learned to like really
score you know to picture and you know
wow do that whole thing and
and uh it was amazing and that's what
i've been doing ever since
you know that's how i got here today
because because bill
you know because i do the music for f is
for family with bill burr and
you know atc and that's how it's all
amazing
it's [ __ ] beautiful it's art yeah
you're [ __ ] doing your art it's
very delicious man yeah it's cool man
it's uh
it's been really
so so with me with low rider so lowrider
comes out it's up in smoke
it's in this thing and in the 80s 84 i
do bob and tom
and you know i'm a chicano i'm in
indianapolis i'm on the
i'm on the road and and when they
introduced me
as a guest on bob and tom in 1984 they
start
they play low rider other guys here
so i asked those guys i said hey man you
guys
think you could run me just a copy of
low rider you know like you know
and they give it to me on a white
cassette doesn't say anything let's get
some dave
and i would play it when i would walk on
stage because it made me almost feel
like i was home yeah
so never thinking that i would be in a
position to have my own show you know
i had a couple of ideas for songs so as
we're
and warner brothers over there they go
so as we do this show like what's going
to be the theme song and i said oh you
know i had a couple ideas
and the first one was don't let no one
get you down by war and it starts really
slow
and it starts really slow but it once it
starts it's great
and i remember all the executives from
the room and they're like
no what else you got i go
you know hesitantly i i say to the
person
push number six and they push number six
and it goes
down
and everybody goes that's it and that
was it man so
congratulations man because i know i
know what that process is it's beautiful
man
and it's funny how life you know takes
these twists and turns and who you meet
and who goes and what you do and what
you don't do
but they all lead to a good place
if you say yes yeah and you know
whatever chicano part of you said no the
chicano part of me said no
but when i said yes everything changed
man it's yeah it's incredible
and i'm i'm glad to have had that
experience
in such a succinct way you know where i
can go like oh this is what happened
that was a thing it changed my life
instead of you know because you have
those experiences once in a while you
say yes to stuff
out of taking contrary maybe somebody
has an easy answer oh i did this or i
did that
yeah but when it happens like that there
is no easy answer yeah because it's like
it's being slapped in the head it's
almost like um
it's um
something saying well this had to happen
and that had to happen
and you had to go over there to iowa
yeah to come back
you had to do this you had to do that
you had to go to this and then it all
it all comes together i mean nothing's
an accident but yeah i mean it's
definitely
it's like i remember hearing this saying
like uh you know whatever your view of
god or whatever you know higher power
with this or that blah blah
you know it's like i remember uh someone
saying
you know uh coincidence is god's way of
remaining anonymous
you know and it's like dude there's got
to be something up there because i
couldn't have manufactured
any of these stories to happen the way
they happened
you know what i mean to like any of them
why are you
yeah what like in johnny rockets i say
yes and then the [ __ ]
the whole of my life changes or you know
i'm bummed out because duff's like
i'm gonna i'm gonna do this thing oh
yeah you know
and then it's like at that moment i
thought it's over
you know and i'll go back to doing this
in zafarnado there was a buddhist temple
in san fernando and you would see these
buddhists in in in san francisco i was
with my grandmother who was very mean
and you know my grandma thought they
were
christians you know and i would be like
you know grandmother buddhist
and and and and uh she would say
uh you know harry christians want
you know they wanted money or anything
and i would say you know their buddhist
they don't want anything and my grandma
would say
everybody wants something yeah that was
her
really her philosophy so so whatever i
moved to there was a buddhist temple i
moved to sherman oaks and up the street
there's a buddhist
temple and then when my show started i
bought a house in hawaii
and at the top there was a buddhist
temple and then i live
you know where i live in l.a there's a
buddhist temple
and then in my darkest times like
through my divorce
uh i was really just you know
like just i didn't want to live and i
thought
whoa what what do i need to do
to not wish anybody any harm you know
because
that's really what it it came down to
and and when i got apple tv
there was all these documentaries and
then i saw one of the the llama the doc
you know
it was just about you know staying there
and just being at the moment and
not wishing anybody any harm or or or
just you know being kind to people and
it it
and that started to just attach
everything from san fernando all through
my life and
i was like i think i think i almost want
to you know follow the principles of
this so so
i i look in the computer and i go where
was it done i'm going to be you know
and he's going to be in boston at this
time and uh
i went to go see him and i had two
tickets but i only went by myself
so when he came out um
he shook my hand and there was a person
a monk that was with him in the front
and i said hey would you like to sit in
my seat and and you know i had this
empty seat and he sat there and
you met the dude it
just changed everything it's incredible
yeah it's it's funny when you
when you want it's almost like you know
when you have those bigger moments in
your life and you want to do them by
yourself
you know what i mean like if you there's
a movie comes out even and you're just
like i'm gonna go see that by myself
like i remember i used to watch chavez
you know julio cesar chavez
was like my favorite fighter back in the
day yeah and i would like
i would like take my rent money buy the
pay-per-view
and watch it by myself because i didn't
want i didn't want to hear people
talking like other people's [ __ ] and
i was just like
i'm just gonna watch chavez by myself
you know like
or whatever it was because it's like
yeah you know you wouldn't
or you wouldn't have the same experience
whatever whatever leads anybody to
anything
yeah it's a good thing so wrap it up
bang what a
what some people have come to a fork in
the road and i'm just kidding
it's been you're like yeah you came to
my fork in the road [ __ ]
could be over be over there in the red
river area that'd be the red roof in
you know what i'm gonna tell you
something about this guy right here you
know people always say oh you're so mean
to him in the thing
but when my when my show started in in
um nobody wished me well
nobody wished me success nobody said hey
man i saw you this i saw you there
and this dude right here would call me
and say i saw you in tv guy and
i saw you here there you know nobody and
then when i needed to uh replace the guy
i was working with i said why it's got
to be somebody that you know i get along
with
and i and it was my man right there yeah
16 years ago
so life is good very proud and uh dave
kushner what a pleasure
thanks for letting us in on your life
and your wild ride uh congratulations on
all
all your successes thank you so much for
being here yeah thanks it was great to
uh
it was a great way to spend it let me
tell you something if i leave this
podcast right now and hit my head and
uh i don't make it this is the best part
of kinda stop being a part of the best
podcast i've ever
listened to and and thank you for i
think i feel the same dude
yeah right on i think i feel the same it
was very special
yeah well done all right thanks
everybody hey
and you don't have to be bald to be a
[ __ ] chicano so
you know you're trying to have a
mustache you gotta have the cold yeah
i fought for years to [ __ ] have my
hair long and then cholo shave their
heads
yeah well thank you all right thank you
very much
good to see you guys i'm out awesome man
thank you man